[Music]
welcome back to the off the record where
we're talking about
whatever we want and it's casey's
birthday
happy birthday hey hey hey hey
hey hey oh yeah we gotta [ __ ] them up
tradition
three thirty three three am i the
youngest one in here
yeah no nick is oh yeah you're the baby
i'm 34. look at that
[ __ ] 17 bro yeah i'm like
yeah no you're 33 he's did you even turn
30 how old were you
28. loser you are a baby
i thought anthony was like 25 girls i am
wait a minute
i'm almost 10 years older than you what
the [ __ ] yeah you're my uncle dude
bart literally that's the age of my
oldest nephew i'm hanging out with my
uncles right now dude
all you guys are uncle gusting my
youngest brother's a year older than you
that's [ __ ] weird to me yeah you were
born in the 90s
92 was when i was born wow real piece of
[ __ ]
i got to start kicking it with my nephew
then because i thought he was a little
booger but now i'm like but if you're
willing to kick it with him then it's
like if you want to kick with me the
same [ __ ]
bam how do you feel like does it feel
different from 32
or like [ __ ] no you feel closer to going
to 35 really no
no no no not 35.
i feel like it feels all the same i feel
like i'm still like like what you said
before
but i've matched you when you hit like
30 and i was still like in my 20s i was
like what does it feel like to be 30 you
know
30 no he's he's 30 something but like
i'm saying like when he did turn 30 i'm
like [ __ ] what does it feel like and
you're like it just feels like the same
i'm the oldest [ __ ] here you look like
you're [ __ ] from the 14th century
you're the last man 140. or ninja
turtles three yeah yeah
three yes the best of all three are
definitely the best yeah when they go
back in time
i think yoshi i'm the oldest
steve is the no barter's the second
steve is the third
what about you you're in 1984 uh 86 i'm
35
next month you casey and then nick
but we all agree that we're all we feel
like we're 20 this time yeah yeah yeah
you guys look like you're all 20 but
crossing the 35 mark did feel weird
though i'm like [ __ ] i'm getting close
to 40.
and it's like it's like you don't hear
that line it's almost pushing like no
and like in 40s like right here you get
really really really close it feels
really weird yeah but you're going to be
hot at 40. you'll be fine yeah bro look
how
hot but the number just feels weird
though it's just a weird i don't want to
be like
you know we have a furniture store
trying to buy a couch or something like
how old are you i'm like
40. but people are surprised when you
tell them how old you are though
aren't they yeah you still get carded
yes i do you'll have one
one body fat percentage and you'll have
like
one the tiniest little sliver of silver
and you're like i'm
40. [ __ ] you
he's like i got all these gray hairs
it's like
yeah he's unbelievable let's do a
college gig thing recently a speaking
thing where like you're
you're flyer like what what year was uh
that photo taken yeah they took that one
from like
we're like like 1980. we're 27 i think
when we did it look exactly the same in
the photo no
i don't okay so maybe maybe yeah maybe
your skin is a little bit younger
but man your muscles
they got muscles i know it's your
birthday but we just want to talk about
how hot
i just think you're so [ __ ] hot man
that's my birthday
yeah we'll get we'll get to it we'll get
you supreme
your muscles look older too i know
they're starting to droop a little bit
they're starting to get a little bigger
bro we got man yeah the
i feel like the bones are getting
thicker and i'm just naturally like oh
[ __ ] my friends look good
i'm not even i'm not you're just
naturally getting swole that's [ __ ]
awesome
i didn't have that problem at 33. it's
coming later it's coming
the trick to the dab bar is we all do it
at the same time and then chicks don't
have a choice
yeah that's true this guy's ruining the
[ __ ] curve this guy huh
he's getting all sorted famously
[Laughter]
y'all see no will smith though dad bob
dick
that like broke the internet for some
reason everyone's posting dad bods now
dude what they want to be i want to see
it he's got like ability right now
he's got to be 50 right he put out a
good photo and honestly when i scrolled
past it i thought it was brilliant
he just like let it all hang out he's
like i'm gonna be real with y'all it's
the worst shape i've been in my life did
you say that yeah
it was just the most real thing that i
just felt see him in like bad boys we
saw him play ali
i am legend yeah like he's just that's
why everyone likes will smith though you
know
like this guy all right i remember
looking like that
wait that's actually what i look like
now this morning that's me right now but
just like 18 shades lighter well some
people just
it's always dad bought since they were
born that's like a baby's body that got
muscular that looks like tiger's body
yeah
very true dude how is vegas though how's
vegas yeah
first week right yeah honestly i uh
i actually like it a lot more than i
thought i was gonna like it
what so you thought you're gonna like it
but now you're just like even more great
well like i think when we moved it was
like a very logical move like looking at
finances and like
the stuff that we want where we want to
be in five years with the family and
stuff
and then you go you go check it out
you're kind of looking at it with the
very like
cerebral brain right like is this a good
move because you know like uprooting
your whole family and moving it
somewhere else it's not like just going
to college somewhere else it's like a
big move and you're
so you're constantly thinking you're
very like heady about it but then once
once we got there and we're actually
living it i'm like [ __ ]
this place is tight because like things
that
growing up in l.a your whole life you
just kind of get used to seeing
trash everywhere on the freeway you just
it becomes part of the norm so now when
you're driving you don't see
trash right and so when you go there
just living there for like a week or two
now
i'm used to that freeway and then when i
come back to l.a i'm like what the [ __ ]
do people just dump trash everywhere
here yeah like yes
finally yeah i don't know you have a
different answer you have a different
perspective
and you know when you go to hawaii and
you're like [ __ ] the air feels different
and it's like crystal clear
well vegas is pretty close to la so the
transition isn't that hardcore it's not
like you step off the plane and you're
like
damn it's like hd here but living there
for a little bit and then driving back
i'm like oh [ __ ] there is a constant
haze
in la oh yeah but i didn't realize there
was until i was there long term yeah so
it's just like little things like that
and you're like oh [ __ ] why is this
place so nasty
that's how that's how i felt like this
so you hate california yeah you don't
like l.a we still live here about
easy easy man jesus christ i'm going to
vegas then
so describe so this is your first week
coming to jk from vegas did you drive
here like what's the routine now so
i'm gonna try yeah everyone thinks
you're gonna quit jk because
you moved like two hours away yeah so i
was gonna
i was gonna try a couple of different
things um
i was gonna fly but then this time i
still have a bunch of errands i stuff to
run
while i'm here so i'll just drive so
that way i don't have to like uber 20
different places the next
in two weeks when i come back i'll be
flying and what's cool is
um since my flights are opposite of
people's trends
it's actually way cheaper so you know
like on the weekend everyone is flying
to vegas
i mean i'm flying back from vegas but
i'll be flying here and then so like
my plane when i'm picking my seats
they're all empty all the time
which i'm like that's pretty what do you
mean they fly to vegas on a weekend so
people usually go there like thursday
friday night
oh but then i'm coming here yeah you
know and then people after they're done
partnering saturday sunday to get ready
for monday that's when they're leaving
but that's why i'm going back
so i'm constantly on like almost the
opposite side of the freeway that's
going to work
is it because a lot of people that go to
vegas to party and play is from la
oh yeah i think so so oh that's why so
it's like going against traffic
yeah that's tight wait where where do
you stay when you come back because
you're like here for a couple days right
yeah so i'm staying
at geo's mom's house in east l.a it's
like down the street
oh la familia so how long does it drive
three hours right
about four hours okay about four hours
three hours with speeding i remember
those days
i don't do that anymore but yeah it's
three hours with speeding
two and a half you know give it to me
going 120 you know yeah
we made it to vegas that's like hella
fast i made it to three hours yeah
you just gotta stay above 90 the whole
time not that anyone does that but
and you got to go out at night dude
that's the thing you go at night when
there's no traffic okay that's what it
is
i'm like well i get slowed down every
time because of the traffic you don't
want to go in the daytime yeah you don't
want to go in the day it's too hot
the real degenerate way of doing vegas
is you call up your friends at 10 pm you
go what are you doing tonight i don't
know you want to go play poker i
we're not going to the indian casino
we're going to vegas all right
and then you [ __ ] drive there and
then you start playing poker
and then the next day when you can check
in you book a hotel yeah and you've been
up for like over 24 hours oh [ __ ]
or stay at bart's house now that's dj
jim [ __ ] gio's mom's house gio's mom
says
jio's mom's house or bart's house either
one okay
real dj [ __ ] is you have comps because
you play so much
and then you just stay wherever for free
do real djen [ __ ] is having an m life
card and you put
[ __ ] everything on it like me and
nikki do so we can go play in vegas easy
that's tight yeah love it we did that
together yeah
you get free but they [ __ ] you on that
dude they sent me emails and they're
like
yo come stay for free right and i'm like
oh [ __ ] free rooms
and then you go and you book it and then
later it's like 60 bucks a day from
taxes
oh that's true the the the resort fee
resort fee
hotel tax [ __ ] all this [ __ ] i'm
like what the [ __ ] dude
subdue [ __ ] what does it even go to the
city yeah of course they're just trying
to find
more ways to like lower the price but
not their revenue goes towards like the
pick up the trash off the freeway fee
yeah so it looks better than that's
worth it because bart's dumping all his
trash in vegas
what to this guy he's littering me
driving around with the california plate
though i do feel like people stare and
she people flip you up
[ __ ] in california behavior are you sure
it's not because you're like a [ __ ]
asian buffalo
[Laughter]
today's video is brought to you by hbmn
i'm actually really excited when they
hit us up
and that's because the reason why i got
so cut is i've been on keto
yeah i've been fasting i've been cutting
out sugar
it looks like you're working too and
i've been working out yeah
and i lost about 40 pounds it's pretty
damn amazing
but really good here's the thing man
like
i don't know if you guys done keto but
it kind of sucks
like you get bored you want tasty things
you need variety you need variety
yeah so when i found out about hvmn i
was like
okay we have alternatives here i gotta
do the same things
anymore and i don't have to feel like
you know
this guy that's like doing the weird
thing you know like
i'm i'm on this special diet like i can
actually consume
coffee now and um instead of adding like
latte or whatever i got this cool little
keto powder
or whatever like i could just change it
up and i can add new flavors to my mouth
yeah they also have the keto food bar
yeah thank goodness you want a little
snack and you're like ah man i could be
eating no snickers bar
i want to be healthy then get the keto
food bar has all kinds of flavors so you
can pack it with you
if you need a healthy snack you want to
stay on your keto you want to stay
making healthy choices you can
they got keto collagen powder for the
nails
and those joints and that beautiful hair
and they also have the mct
oil if you're trying to get those
healthy fats in a lot of people like to
mix it with their coffee in the
beginning of the day
and right now they have a special offer
for you guys if you go to hbmn.com
off the record you get 10 off your first
order so if you've been looking for
something
to help you with your keto or if you
want to give keto a try go to hvmn.com
off the record to get 10 off your first
order it's a new
awesome way and a good alternative
to doing something different and when
you're trying keto
i hands down believe in this method i
think that
keto is probably i wish i knew much more
about it earlier because
it was the most effective in helping me
get fit no i was at the gas station
right and i was pumping gas
and this dude roll up in the harley and
he's like this that this white guy looks
like he's like a neo-nazi like [ __ ]
tattoos all over the place
and he rolls up and he goes hey i'm like
oh [ __ ] is that asian haitians about to
happen to me right now i'm
asking hey and then he was like he was
like hey where'd you get your roof rack
[Laughter]
and we started talking about off-road
vehicles and stuff
in a different state i'm like you just
feel different you know when you're
different i was like
under a threat
shark right now no no
there's always witnesses he doesn't even
stop he just pulls out the camera
what's up man what's up i like the idea
that he's
he's going around to beat up asians and
he's like i want hi a high difficulty
one
i need to have the difficulty slider all
the way back
everyone's doing like elderly women and
stuff like that they're looking at bart
like that's my next target
i'm not a [ __ ] i'm not a [ __ ]
they never go for guys that aren't like
cables no i wouldn't grandma's dude
yeah it's always [ __ ] up so um do you
feel like you're a true
nevadian now what do you call your
peoples nevadians
yeah yeah no not
not yet i don't think republican do you
feel like all of your uh
neighbors are californians uh my one
so one that uh lives right across from
me
he's uh from mississippi and he bounced
back and forth from florida to vegas
and i was like oh the tax-free state's
on oh yep
did he come and introduce himself to you
immediately um i just said hi and he
came yeah he came right right up
wow that's not california [ __ ] at all no
you don't say hi to your neighbors
[ __ ] no you don't even look at your
neighbors no they might skin you
tomorrow
night brought me a banana bread like him
and his family were super where did joe
live
crazy forget he lives in a rain forest
yes right
that's true yeah he came an offer a
banana bread
that was super cool him and his wife
were from mississippi and then
my other neighbor he's from from san
francisco he said he [ __ ] hates it
so he lives here they give you banana
bread
yeah i thought that only happens in
movies bro i thought it was gonna be
like meatloaf
yeah yeah yeah yeah like casserole it's
like this is like this is my favorite
place and
it's talking like that oh [ __ ]
somebody's outside with jambalaya
this is my stereotypes you're gonna like
yeah
yeah just like really return the favor
but here's some spring rolls
and a fortune cookie for you dude if you
guys have a block party that is a true
like neighborhood
yeah that's i always wanted to do that
as a kid
because i see it in movies and i see
like people doing it yeah but
i don't think it's a la thing you had
pizza parties in virginia
pizza party block pizza parties did you
order
no my neighbor would wood fire make
pizzas what
what and the whole neighborhood where
all you pizza together was [ __ ] sick
yeah that's what i really wanted for
like taika is to have because i grew up
not
like it was our street wasn't that tight
it wasn't like the parents knew each
other
but all the kids did so like let's say
if one day i decided to sneak off
um and go play with my friends and i
didn't tell my mom
she could just go knock on doors and
know which house i'll be in
oh yeah it's not like that anymore i
don't think so i don't think kids like
i don't know if the street's that tight
or you just don't trust your neighbors
guys carino
everyone's doing it on just you know you
know that [ __ ] where people go like
hey don't [ __ ] discipline my kid yeah
like that's kind of the opposite when i
was growing up
everybody's parents kept us all in check
and they all had each other's permission
to [ __ ]
like lay into us yeah like hey elbows
off the table like it could be all the
different kids
elbows off the table no chewing with
their like mouth uh clothes or
party true open open no don't cheat wait
what
they let you with their mouth open like
that [ __ ] didn't work on us that was
normal
stephen paul you better put your [ __ ]
helmet on steve
that was all my neighbors dude they knew
you're getting all day oh yeah they all
over a second i was like
they would all kick your ass if you
weren't if you're [ __ ] around
this is in in virginia never do that's
how it kind of should be though
as the asian kid i was always like
following the rules i feel like it was
all my white friends that
got super in trouble got slapped yeah i
got slapped at home i got beat but like
they
they got like did you feel like you
didn't know the rules so you were extra
like no i was like
why do these homeboys like like my white
friends were like just like talk back to
their parents i was like this is amazing
that's crazy that is unacceptable yeah
when i was growing up i didn't know
table like american table manners or
whatever like it's like you know chinese
like eating you just kind of reach
across and pick up stuff in the middle
like it's family style oh my gosh
yeah i would do that at the end of my
white friend's
dinner table and the parents would be
like casey what are you doing
ask for the mashed potatoes don't just
reach yeah pass it yeah i'm like oh
okay well real asian styles you grab the
mashed potatoes you slap it on everyone
else's plate and then you put it on
yours
and they'll be like what the [ __ ] it
means you gotta wait for the elders to
eat yeah you gotta wait for sitting
there with your food you're like
any time now hurry up i remember going
to like my non-asian friend's house when
it's like
10 people and we run like we're gonna go
from the front yard run through the
house into the backyard
everyone just stamped in i'm the one
that's like
[Laughter]
so used to just running right through i
was like why did you take your shoes off
right now
wait for me guys you want to get it
illegal the invisible lava there she
can't step on there
all your friends look back [ __ ] idiot
put your shoes on what are you doing for
your birthday
nothing i'm not a big birthday
celebration kind of person is anyone
here a birthday person i don't know i
mean
we're men here getting [ __ ] up yeah
that's good
he's like i like parties yeah i like
celebrating for
the whole month birthday month everybody
yeah yeah those are cool like i usually
have like a drink at night but like i'm
definitely having like three on my
birthday at least
like i think you're the most normal guy
here too yeah what's the difference
what we don't even care about our
brother i think that's
a lot of guys that we know though but i
don't think we're normal
are you sure like casey at work on his
birthday
we all do that right but i don't think
that's normal like i think the normal
people take off
on their birthday it's my birthday i
ain't doing it not working today
those people are [ __ ] annoying though
yeah anthony
what i don't work on your birthday or
not
yeah yeah i do actually yeah but i
i also like play really hard on my
birthday this birthday i'm probably
gonna treat myself to like a bunch of
crypto
that's the next month you said hey yo oh
i think anthony likes events
i think so too i think that's and then
normal people just try to [ __ ] escape
from life
i like events too but i don't i don't
know how to think about them
i do enjoy hosting events from time to
time i like doing other people's events
if it's an event for me i don't know
yeah it feels like self-absorbent or
something like i don't like all you like
it's like today you're asking me about
my brother and like
i don't i [ __ ] [ __ ] my birthday i'm
going to self-absorb so hard next month
i'm gonna invite you guys i'm gonna have
like a minimum like crypto gift
deposit tree registry yeah
registry like you gotta show up and give
me like 35 dogecoin it's my you know i'm
35. that'll be tight
you know what i'm saying i can afford
that don't jack my idea that's a good
idea that's a great idea is it a crypto
registry like you choose the coins or
can we just give you any coins you can
give me anything but if you give me
really really shitty stuff and it's like
a red line that day you have to give me
double dude at my own wedding this is
absolutely true story anybody went to my
wedding will tell you
i was getting people to buy ethereum
with their phones
yeah i was i was like get setting them
up on coinbase during my the reception
losing your vows and like it's like a
bunch of people are like is this the one
is this the site i'm like yeah that's
the one
and then it's called what theory and
what and i'm like yeah [ __ ] yeah buy
that [ __ ] yeah like
your referral code on like vacation
i wish i did that i didn't even trust it
back then you made them so much money oh
yeah i did
i i was a couple hundred bucks it was
like 120 bucks just 150 bucks
okay so i'm definitely taking advantage
of this you know
registry you do that you do you still
got a chance man it's the morning
that's true like not even noon yet yeah
we'll we'll wrap today at
six and then uh we'll we'll you know
tips at home waiting for me so we'll do
something
hey yo what was that about bro
hey man are you talking about
masturbation tonight
[Music]
you